bin wieder da ja ohne bh leute haben
diskutiert hey ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich was hier gerade für ein
cooles t shirt an habe dieses t shirt
jetzt das offizielle dick und doof merge
meine lieben freunde das kommt am 11 12
allerdings soll es heute nicht immer
neues merchandise gehen sondern ihr witz
bereits im titel eingeblendet ich schaue
mir heute mal deutsche günstig talks an
von daher ich direkt auf place
[Musik]
nicht so schnell
ich
hab jetzt schon kein bock mehr gehen
raten daten daten daten daten daten
dafür
der tanz denn so die machen einfach so
was
schaue ich mir hier gerade
er habe ich nicht verstanden oder am die
tik tok nicht verstanden
[Musik]
ja kein kommentar
ja also ich meine ich hab ja auch über
der zeit lang aktiv tech talks
hochgeladen werden
nein
[Musik]
aber wir gerade gesehen habe waren
deshalb zumindest teilweise auch sachen
wo ich mir wirklich mühe gegeben habe
entweder bei der vorbereitung über den
gummibärchen oder teilweise auch im
schnitt danach aber hier
das sieht nach zehn sekunden dahin
geschützten irgendwie aus ich weiß auch
allgemein nicht optik doch überhaupt
noch so das ding ist also früher musical
i ging ja voll durch die decke jetzt
heißt es ja tik tok
ich weiß nich nutzt ihr selbst tik tok
soll ich selbst weil wieder aktiver
werden auf tik tok ihr könnt gerne hier
abstimmen und mir dass uns in die
kommentare schreiben
ihr könnt ihr gerne euro tik tok namen
und in die kommentare schreiben ich
schaue ich dann mal bei euch vorbei aber
ja wir schauen uns setzen weiter german
grunge tik tok sand
[Musik]
da immer irgendwie so hin und
hergerissen ich weiß halt nicht ob die
leute das wirklich ernst meinen und sich
denken
da steckt richtig viel arbeit drin das
ist cool das lade ich hoch oder ob sie
sich selbst ein bisschen auf die schippe
nehmen und das ganze tik tok gamer auf
die schippe nehmen was ich will ja immer
ungern dann was zu sagen weil vielleicht
verletzt es irgendjemanden wisst ihr was
ich meine
ja wie gerade bereits gesagt ich sage
einfach mal nicht zu den wieder da ohne
bh heute abend diskutiert wenn es
wunderbar da hat eine hühnchen auf dem
kopf das ist eine ganz böse bitte die
ich heute schlucken muss das beste am
heutigen video ist dieses t shirt jetzt
endlich kommen shop.de fick dich alex
hat eine scheiß presse hat ein
hektisches schloss konntest du das tun
nach hannah ich habe ich gebraucht
du bist der einzige der mich vertraut
der einzige ist was drin ist
das war von thorsten riedl 2 warum macht
man dazu so einen tick tock allein da
sind mehr als zwei leute haben sprechen
wie bereits gesagt entweder jacky ickx
tik tok nicht oder die leute verhindern
bisschen was falsch allerdings wie
bereits gesagt ich möchte überhaupt
keiner person irgendwie zu nahe treten
oder irgendeine person persönlich
attackieren oder beleidigen oder sonst
was nämlich reagiere hier nur auf dieses
video german grunge tik tok ich weiß
nicht mal mehr die leute sind die teile
da hochladen also bitte nehmt euch meine
reaktion nicht zu herzen und ich will
sagen wir schauen uns noch drei letzte
german tecdax an manche nacht schreibe
ich den namen auf einer rakete und hofft
dass mit explodiert
[Musik]
ok
du willst
besser hat
jakob doch doch einfache war den sie da
ja ohne bh leute haben diskutiert das
reicht dann auch schon wieder an der
stelle des heutigen wie die jetzt auch
beenden beide lieben freunde wenn euch
meine reaktionen auf einige der
krassesten german grunge tech talks
gefallen hat das unbedingt einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da schreibt
mir wie bereits gesagt gerne in die
kommentare ob ich mal wieder aktiver
werden so luftig talk ich hätte dort
laser luca genauso wie auch auf
instagram dann könnte ich mir auch gern
folgen schreibt mir gerne auch euren
tipp topp namen und in die kommentare
auch wie bereits gesagt das t shirt hier
reingesteckt dick und doof kommt am
ersten zwölf in den shop
[Musik]